from screen junkies studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie by now your host Andy signor for
now hello screen jockeys welcome another
episode of we face is going to be a fun
one we have some awesome topics today
and three wonderful guests well excited
and watch along today we're going to be
arguing over what movie is the biggest
improvement over its source material a
lot of ways you go with that what movie
would inspire the best team hotel and
what Avenger is the most replaceable all
fun stuff and you're watching live on
screen duckies plus you can use the
hashtag movie fights live will be
watching along Dan Marella fat chicken
as always how's it going damn good how
are you Andy welcome back look I know
it's been that we were at Star Wars
Celebration it kicked me kicked my butt
a little bit yeah
tens con we were in black and white left
yeah you got rain on awesome classic
fights thanks Alicia and the whole crew
it was wonderful too much fun so much
fun well we're back and let's introduce
today's fighters I'm so happy to have
them you know um he was in grand
Budapest hotel dope and he's going to be
in a little movie called spider-man I
think it's called
spider-man spider-man like Durban so
happy to have him back Tony really
really wrote that first time I screwed
up on perfect that's right
I know Tony read Laurie oh do it
you did perfect I'm the worst at name I
can't pronounce things everyone can tell
me but no Tony so God have you back and
you had a good stuff I know you're
working on I'm excited that you're here
again nervous no good not in like a time
secondary with Marc but did win what did
yes good one huh
so your loans are coming too cocky
slightly just I mean alright I guess
what hard can Hector
yeah you smoke well guess what my next
guest also one last time on a big show
the harry potter fight yeah you be our
own Spencer Gilbert he was Pitt I did
knock but she's also written on Cartoon
Network's Regular Show and Powerpuff
Girls pollito CID downhearted I know her
you got their revenge
that revenge is just my thing I'm going
to I get the Barons name yeah you
already got it right huh what I did
welcome back to you know thank you good
to get around now two winners yeah
you're back want to know mm-hmm so one
of you is going to lose - no it's just
doing the two of us oh yeah one of you
is definitely gonna lose two of you
could be yeah oh man it's all up to this
man here so happy to have a making his
debut he also just took up the role of
Tom servo and my favorite shows of all
time Mystery Science Theater 3000 and a
new pilot so if you've got a lot of
stuff going on Baron oh yeah my way and
oh I'm good to see ya
mess of the name alright dammit it's
Brian bond no it's uh good to be here
I'm happy to be here for my first slash
last time oh god I'm from Vegas I play
poker I get you in the zone he's really
bad for you Californians play I brought
treats for everyone oh he brought us
Marcia out he's got that sympathy bow
he's got the food boat what do I have
look at this this looks I'm totally
needs you guys can share those I'm oh
yeah Danny when immersed in vanilla bean
marshmallow oh my god this looks
incredible my belly I know when I
brought it I kind of surviving the judge
not in the ekp none of those I mean I
did I did it for everyone including the
people back there like the N will share
their funding with the psych-out I'm
Parker get out there this is good like
stress relief you know so yeah basically
she just like oh they're eating me oh
yeah it's leading me good risk the
Registry's all right well guys this is
gonna be a fun one again you guys know
preparing your first time it's all
because although the passion facts
creativity or you want to win this
debate okay whatever you you put you
picked on the sheet to spend it with
your life until the bell is gone which
isn't here hopefully someone can get me
to bail I relative bail when you hear
the bell then you can win in complaints
of Batali's then you can tell us how you
really feel okay till then fight this
like it's a like it means it any
questions alright grab one let's do that
though let's do
I want to fight you keep a slight match
let inside stop to fight out to change
this they can do a better montage keep
fans submitted another montage right
fine that's providing it's ok it's fine
we there's better fight words out there
I miss let them fight I have sentimental
attachment to the first one yeah so and
I feel like I'm going to stick to my
brother on the first one bad as Santa's
and like someone out there headed
together a really tight one got a quick
tight tight tight tight tight tight
tight tight
does that Richie bad Zuko Zuko yeah
pretty good alright round one okay this
is a all this talk of the Marvel had
some sort of big event we were there I
guess news was there covering at their
open house where they talked about all
the Marvel things and they've said
guardians 3 is going to be the next
phase of the future of Marvel and all
what does that mean so this just brought
the question which I thought was a
little fitting I'm just curious of all
the Avengers we know now which avenger
actor is most replaceable and I want you
to explain how you would replace them
how they would do it but who is the one
avenger you think you know what we could
toss them out and the fans aren't going
to lose it we can we can still fix this
Toni Oates go with you first who is the
most replaceable Avenger for my answer
I'm going Chris Evans as Captain America
you know that guy no never measured the
foot in my life what no comment what uh
do I explain why I give me a quick quick
quick I think he's very replaceable
because we've been setting up him
leaving for already a couple of movies
by introducing Winter Soldier and Falcon
ok great whenever I love it alright
we'll hear more and there's more 15 Gina
who are you thinking ok I'm going with
Jeremy Renner because I think personally
Jeremy Renner is kind of a piece of crap
and I don't want to have work anymore
uh he's a little bit sexist but also
hydrosoul say to you I just don't think
he's he's a good actor who isn't a
superhero action hero whereas the others
in the in the franchise I think are good
actors who also are superhero action
here
jeremy renner is great when he's like a
creeping things but I just think he
doesn't in Avengers Earth's Mightiest
Heroes the animated series he talked I
was my favorite character because he was
funny he was like that world's flash and
Renner doesn't bring any of that to it
and I understand that some of it is
acting or is writing but also I feel
like make the most of what you're given
Renner gives me something if I and if I
replace them I would replace them with
ruth negga because I want more ladies
and more POC in my Avengers Baron you
want to get Renner him um I would go
with one trestle in has no hon I'm
always finding where place why they call
me Punta de Lyonne I would get rid of
Chris Hemsworth okay the other Chris
because nothing says space like an
Australian doing a British actor and so
I would want to probably actually have
some um you there I would shout out to
kat dennings I would want to replace
Chris Hemsworth well he's pretty
replaceable I think with you know he
could be anybody from Ryan Gosling too
you know Bradley Cooper or James Franco
I prefer a young Brendan Fraser but uh
yeah so I think you can get Chris with
Hemsworth out of there and replaced with
Liam oh so you're going with another
camera that looks very similar to it no
I'm joking I don't want to carry one you
mean they're all like clunky white dude
yeah cuz they all look the same that's
like Jane Foster yeah you're very
Portman is an amazing actress yeah I
replace or or British Natalie Portman
also known as Keira Knightley you can
just put her there
yeah yeah no please play cable oh we
played big hole by Deadpool all right
you're like little guys in the lineup
you didn't know that he said like Oh
some of these guys are super you'd be
like oh that's why I don't work in
Hollywood
three sevens chris hemsworth you look at
them you're like oh crap I don't want to
fight you guys look at Jeremy Renner and
you're like you're kind of a wiener no
okay okay you got along his line and I
just say something one I think he's a
very nice guy
you know him he's also a bad guy
jeremy renner oh yeah I was great an
arrival - you're the reason you are here
only the most replaceable it seems like
it's more of a personal attack I'm
Jeremy runner is there something else
attention oh and actually it being a
reason Chris Evans is perfect to be
replaced because we we have said of him
being replaced by either Falcon like in
the comic books for by Winter Soldier
was all like I'm anything and I mean
they've been poisoning for this because
they have no idea if Chris Evans is
going to recited contract or not so
regardless he's they've been doing that
ready and so I think they have an inner
workings of the Marvel contract but
here's the thing
let him know now they're doing their
stuff or something can you ask real name
everyone in the Avengers they would
forget and Jeremy Renner within it
cookies in it so little so he's so easy
to replace a few like listen whatever
they might have been checking that he
has in the first Thor was exactly what
made me go oh Jeremy Renner's even I
wonder who he's playing was excited when
I saw him at door and then he did not
want to sound there yeah we have up to
it in any of the Avengers movies right
but cuz by coming back to soar real
quick which is I think of the three Thor
movies the first one is probably going
to be the worst one because the second
one I thought was better the third one
it looks fantastic because of how to
sort the hammer
golly makes everyone breakfast that's
why I don't really know where flow
regimes are there was Gary a one-night
stands the least he could do is get that
right I made him worthy and that's
yes sure cigar well I'm just saying I
don't think that that's what makes him
worthy but if a different actor could
have gotten in there and made it make
sense to me that like oh this guy was
kind of a dick and now he's making
people eggs so I guess I believe that he
feels he's worthy of the hammer but
here's a method that's like a character
thing you're not saying the actor no I
am saying that be a different actor
could have totally made that work for me
sure Chris Hemsworth did not make it
work for me he was the exact same thing
the entire movie somebody else that can
make that change would make me change
and I was like killing my Michael
Jackson if you want to make the world a
better place take a look at yourself and
make a change now whoo whoo Chris
Hemsworth question way before we 10 you
are you just removing for him as the
actor and having sword just be play
something else like Don Cheadle or you
are you out of on title is already
warmish there right it's not like you're
a coward that cut good power back and
make him for that would be fantastic he
seems like he's from space there's one
there's one of the mountie how are you
are you just replacing them done she
sounds like you're actually saying no
Captain America will be Winter Soldier
or fell we try to play our youtube and
using mythology he's being rewarded or
you replace reactor and replace the
actor but I will also say that there's
only one of the three options we said
there's only one guy who hasn't gotten
his whole movie so that should be an
indication of how much these guys are
like you're very sure you chose a
character Hawkeye I mean you really
can't have it though movement okay but
everyone thought I had amazing okay I am
really MIDI universe can I have a song
that absolutely Iron Man aesthetic
inaudible you know why because no one
gives a crap that I don't get Jeremy
Renner is on movie no one wants this one
bad he's a great supporting character
and for you Black Widow had her own
movies as well Luci and Michelle she
talked my jack we go I mean with
Emsworth he is very synonymous to that
for look yes name about Chris Emma
exactly but that's why I'm saying to
replace him with the different character
in the comic books okay like you're
going on ethology I'm going Misaki and
you can also replace the actor as well
but what one were they most replaceable
and mines as most replaceable because
fans won't get upset point of order he's
already been
been set and sonoran set you know
nothing family the question is an actor
is the most replaceable oh yeah
unnecessarily which character in terms
of how the mythology is being
interpreted I want to see an actor primo
foci yeah the hustla semantics we're
going to play the Hawkeye that I love
from the cartoons and the comics so far
we haven't seen it those other two guys
I have made those that roll their own
they're good I feel like I've seen
enough of them they're both great I want
to see an awesome awesome awesome
Hawkeye and Jeremy Renner is not it for
me okay so final flashes when going
around and mythology is allowed but also
you have to have the carrot the actor
replaced so it's clarifying your last
thoughts on why years is better than
their skin oh okay so why are Emsworth
in a Renner not replaceable Hemsworth is
not replaceable because one he's going
to do an amazing job just from the
trailer that we've seen in Thor idea as
well as he is the character there's no
one who looks like Thor more than him
and he's in bodies out in the way oh
well I'm sorry continue some awake and
and and at the same time he's built the
fan and he's ready to I think grow even
further into this universe now that
they're getting bigger and stuff as for
Renner I feel like it's a personal
attack I like the fact that he's you
know he's at everyday man and the line
he said in Avengers 2 where he's like
I'm fighting these robots with a bow and
arrow and there's people who are fast
and everything that's what makes him so
amazing because he is an everyday man
it's like if you were in this situation
you'd probably be a runner but he still
brings that like thoughts and and and
thinking that it's like this is a crazy
world but I'm going to do the best I can
and I like that about it and as for why
Evans are you giving up and why are
Evans and Hemsworth's not replaceable I
think exactly what Tony was saying
Hemsworth in Thor he's everyone
associated him with that character Evans
is Captain America he was one of the
first guys that people are like holy
crap I believe this dude as a superhero
just look at him just listen to him he's
got the chiseled jaw and everything and
I just think if you polled ten people on
the street and
name the Avengers characters from the
movie as fast as you can
the one guy they would keep leaving out
is Jeremy Renner and it is a gift
Nighthawk is a great character and it
wants me I want to see him service to
the way I know he should be Erin I was
like why are your wire Evans and Renner
not replaceable
okay well Chris Evans I don't think is
replaceable because I actually do think
he's doing a pretty good job as Captain
America especially because I think that
Captain America is sort of he's in every
man and an American every man which
means boring so he's there for a reason
and jeremy renner the dude is quipping
like it's quittin like the guy can
deliver a line so when you need because
with Joss Whedon is like I just need
someone to say a joke here Jeremy it's
really easy for that to happen
chris hemsworth there's a lot of vert
you know there's a lot of like saying
ridiculous things in a very kind of big
Shakespearean way you know like bilge
snipe yeah which is a line from the
first Avengers movie which is the only
blind that I liked that he said by her
movie and then my other favorite
performance of him is saying yes when
the Hulk shows up in the Ragnarok
trailer yeah other than that I could do
without him alright Dan any bad just a
couple things ruth negga actually played
a character on agents of shield named
Rayna she's no stranger to the Marvel
Universe I will say amongst our viewers
at home barons wordplay already a hit
particularly I am a hopeless romantic
and puns DeLeon was very music servos
the two major characters brought it by
people watching at home a Twitter rogue
Raider three spoke for a lot of people
who said seriously no one going for the
actor that's already a replacement they
could literally just not have Bruce
Banner anymore solo just reporting the
whole and then at use of kanessa saying
clearly ass war machine it's already
happened to nobody better than I so
those are the two you mentioned on
Twitter most often of course we have the
Twitter poll that I can share with you
no I disagree we'll enjoy give your
judgement based on the arguments I think
yeah jeanne got a little personal with
them and I just wanted
did you meet him somewhere and he was a
jerk
it was time I yeah I guess I didn't get
that vibe but I'll have to talk to
Morgan like that but yes I guess he's a
sexist creepy jerk because when I wrote
down from yeah I'll have to look again
but so I got hung up on that even though
yes you're right he's Elite popular
Avenger that's a fair argument Hemsworth
so I think they both got you pretty hard
as like he is Thor like that's sort of
what he is and since you even pointed
out the question what actor is most
replaceable he's probably the most
identifiable as Thor and the thor
ragnarok troll or even knew you admitted
like what sort of like oh he's kind of
good yeah there's a Tom Hardy Oh
interesting
could he do I know I heard that yeah
where you can really really do anything
are you comedy he made a bad bang later
on a little bit yeah okay so I can
inception - well if you'd said it in
time maybe you would help but next
didn't so oh I think I got to give it to
Tony and just a little more adding the
mythology levator and the fact you did
point out which I was that scene and
Ultron is a really good moment of
renter's I thought you just had a little
bit more here in the first round so Tony
you ruined I wanna write man well the
Twitter poll was a landslide 71% voted
for Jeremy Renner but I got but I will I
will lay people tweeting along hashtag
movie fights live watching the show tend
to do agree with Tony I saw more people
weighing in on Twitter itself agreeing
with Tony on that right 71% level when
you are aligned all right round two this
one comes off Twitter from Russell
Hoffman the question stems around Ridley
Scott says you may digitally D H
Sigourney Weaver for more alien movies
which I'm still have to process but it
begs the question what role would you
most want to see an older actor revisit
using technology is there one that we
would be excited about Gina let's hear
your pitch I think you're gonna age
someone down agent down all the way
which is why I went Macaulay Culkin home
alone because I think like I want to see
what this technology can do
see adults older macaulay culkin turns
back into ten-year-old macaulay culkin
also his body still young so he can
still do all those wacky hijinx that he
did in the movie and yeah i just want to
see him setting booby traps for for you
know i age everyone in that movie town I
want to see in setting but we traps our
Joe Pesci and uh the other guy whose
name I can't remember right now all
right well I'm there is a mr. u-turn
here we go
it's a certain time it's marginal time
well no it's just out right now that's
before the movie is about to hit 4:20 on
4/20 so I got alright so if you do that
sort of thing at home that's on me or
not desert Ione's Arjuna no they're not
special but I had to point out that
we're taking that one for Lonnie at 4:20
pelisek soaked in the very second but
it's about to be but sorry anyway keep
you encouraged you impaired in your next
Oh me well I keep hearing these phrases
like 40 at the new 30 and 30 is the new
20 so if that means anything it means
that old is the new new I would be aged
mr. Sean Connery to play James Bond once
a game because you know there's a lot of
debate about who's going to play James
Bond next because Daniel Craig seemed to
be done with that so why not go back to
the originator the best James Bond that
there ever was which is Sean Connery and
you know I think he would just be ageing
him and you know of course you get like
a body double and put him put him
straight back in their manual make it
he'll make it work make it work with
that crazy accent he's crazy accent I'd
watch both of these so far Tony
so make me great oh man I would go with
Clint Eastwood demand with their name
trilogy because first off as you can see
I'm helping him out and no one what can
I say I'm supportive I am super said we
got an amazing movie out of hateful
eight and then bringing back the Ennio
Morricone
into that world and how wonderful it is
and could you imagine not
maybe de-aged all the way but in older
Clint Eastwood in the man with no name
trilogy just imagine say the young boy
in the first few dollars more is now
older and he remembers him and is got a
wife and he's there's people there to
kind of you know kill him and the
village he goes to the man blondie
to get trained again and to see an older
Quinte slightly older Dee age but also
slightly older Clint Eastwood go back to
that time that time would be iconic and
amazing as and should I start fighting
them hi ash with Mark on your mouth so
I'm going to feel from it and say I
don't you think I don't think either
those guys are up to the challenge
yeah they're both great in their time
but if you forget the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen these these guys
are not are not up for a movie 99 99
percent of what they do especially
especially such action-heavy movies that
you guys picked 99 percent what they do
and have swapped out by by with a bear
and fed body doubles so then why are
they in that at all okay wrong with that
they're in the front for the eyes when
it first like integral when you come
back to that space and if I walk here
that's my shot
you're gonna steal James Bond from the
clutches of Idris Elba know yourself but
does not want to do it let us let me pan
down here know that result but does not
want to do let me tell you what my buddy
very close personal friend watch like a
last week show guy sorry okay first off
the man with no name shows you barely
has any action and it's all gun shots I
think 20 so we can still pull a gun if
he's directing movies although you ran
Torino Gran Torino was less than what is
seven years ago the man can still pull a
gun and shoot people and direct at the
same time the empty chairs I said are
you sure you still up to the challenge
upholding you know the thing about the
movies that YouTube picks is that
there's nothing interesting about either
of them what they haven't been made for
20 years the James Bond series is still
coming out and judging by the judging by
the Bexar they're about to re Roger
Moore the whole series
you save it and make it relevant again
and how you knew that Sean Cumbre no no
here's what I will say about why
homeboys interesting because even
Skyfall ripped off home alone home alone
can never happened with cellphones ah
hey Kevin are you in the car
it's a hashtag no way not in the films
this is okay you're saying you might
just get one couple of pennant cannot
work in the world cellphones yeah
totally so movies do it all the time
eggless our movies are terrible
what whoo depends which one you're
talking about it's all about oh it
follows but see that's that's thriller
as well they had a phone and Rilla Rilla
things that kill work so they need a
home alone situation not not a horror
film in a home alone situation why would
they not call his cell phone or house
listen when he was all on - lost in New
York there was a phone in that hotel
room
barely show interest roll number he was
there before there was a phone in the
hotel that's not healthy sraw notion
uh-huh well I heard you pitch me his
movie a little bit what is your movie
now why are we bringing them back next
to you baron okay so oh so this is what
this is what I would say I would say
bring them back when in doubt add more
kids maybe aged out a whole bunch of
other actors have a whole bunch of kids
in a house they all got left behind
ah but it's no child left on home alone
yeah exactly it's Superdome along
there's even more robbers this time
since they don't they don't just want to
they don't want to rob a house they want
to beat up and kill the kids whoa the
stakes a little bit and then can young
young baby face Kevin still slapping
that aftershave on it's a how great
would it be to slap an aftershave on an
age down digital creaks oh it looks so
bad look so crazy in a good way but also
the callee halkan is playing this Kelly
yeah was I the only one only three
actors you can steal
sorry yeah being picture all the way was
also Sean Connery was even
movie legal action in it ah let's get a
factory on this because that is
definitely that Sean Connery they'll do
it at the end
Microsoft Sean Connery a James Bond
those movies have evolved from there and
they are no longer those types of movies
the the people watching the Bond movies
now are young people who love The Fast
and the Furious and stuff and they need
that gritty action I don't know if you
if you buy your way huh same thing about
yours about your movies people want that
gritty action exact yeah and you're
talking about westerns yeah but most of
most I mean 80% of the movie is just
plain Eastwood walking around looking
sinister you want to UM able to use to
me seem like really sad things like when
you go back to your high school and you
see your favorite teacher I'm only call
a recess bring them back to a bowl
everyone wants Macaulay Culkin to have a
win in life these other guys might have
our wins people if only don't get her to
make people sad well you know oh my god
remember when James Bond was awesome
ever and Sean Connery was awesome now
look at him but Sophia that is the exact
total it is perfect for espionage so
everyone underestimate a person because
of his age then that's when he goes chub
chops and I wear what is your movie girl
he knows multiple robbers in mobile camp
yes well I think we got it we got a we
got to make the James Bond series
relevant again because I think it's
getting away from it in my personal
opinion inspector quantum songwriting
has one joking good thing said yes so
basically am i James Bond first of all
you know you know wit pan geriatric home
and a because I think Sean Connery's in
his 90s now so you D age him to be in
his 70s alright so that we can still
hold but he's not too old because some
of a good bit of shopping um so then you
have this man that's there who is of
course kind of you know kind of in his
his old
sunglasses and situation he's playing
gin rummy and then next thing you know a
nurse comes in to see patient
man jumps out of the chair chop-chop to
the nurse to the throat throw me a
hospital me scenario yes because he's
undercover because that nurse is also
somebody that is a secret spy that he
had together yeah so he's deep
undercover but you assumed because he's
70 that he must belong there and I'm
saying that's the jumping off point for
also a 7 year old James Bond the rest of
the movie I'm depressed
yes but with Bionic legs yeah because I
didn't do a sequel to James Bond in the
fundamental Nick Cage movie remember
mission increase remember Tom Connolly
played old Robin Hood and how depressing
that was that was amazing no he was he
was it was King Arthur yeah yeah first
night with Larry
personate he was King Arthur Richard
Gere was a Lancelot figure yeah I'm just
saying no one is sad it's a sad thing
alternative dragon from Dragon of a
class [ __ ] don't know my people are
I'm sorry I'm trying to get a hold of my
last saw sister someone can win anyone
to win this because these are all
terrible last sell God okay that's where
Sean Connery and you told it takes a lot
to like th someone and he wouldn't want
to do a James Bond movie because it's
clean it was just I need and and buy too
much action I mean like jumping from one
train to another falling down a bridge
Sean Connery which I also do you want
someone who says it's okay to beat women
with a stick as long as it's no bigger
than your thumb wait now I was getting
personal
I specifically didn't bring up what eats
the crap both of those these bold guys
because I got it for the last time what
it's like to be our entry but I'm better
for him so doesn't we all got one
okay exactly Macaulay Culkin it's sad
also everyone hated when Chris Evans
face was put on the tiny little body in
Captain America one that's exactly what
this would be and it's your secret it
would be so terrible and weird and also
he's the one who looks most different
our two is childhood Boniface Gina okay
I still think if you're going
test out this uh this technology really
test it out and make us an adult idea
again also you guys don't both knocked
each other out by being like your guys
90s your guys in his nineties they can't
do anything so I am saying they can't do
anything Macaulay Culkin's can feel
uh-uhh
pour water outside to make ice he can
still slap on that aftershave he can
still watch movies that he's too young
to see and that sound awesome no
especially because the concept has
already been burned because Macaulay
Culkin did a viral video where he played
Kevin McCallister as an adult and he's
really messed up because he was left
home alone and he's a cab driver now so
the whole movie has been burned so I
want it okay so Clint Eastwood first of
all the last compelling uh performance
that man had was talking to an empty
chair at the RNC and Sean Connery last
company he was kicking ass [ __ ] Ames
so I would just like to see him do that
again you know I'm just saying like
don't underestimate somebody who's had a
hip replacement when the hit has been
replaced with the rocket launcher that
now opens up from the need hearing at
acceptance and you enter in
double-oh-seven into the desperation
pretty early and I disconnected em boom
at the end of it is tough all right Dan
maybe I'll help me here nothing to help
you but stuff from Twitter they're worth
the mccoys from our Twitter viewers
about the knockout rule which was not
invoked but that people did notice they
were there were some enquiries about
that yes Sean Connery oh that's a
knockout Sean Connery's last movie was
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
2003 currently 86 years old
mmm but colleague Kolya did a web video
2015 called just me as a house by myself
which in which he unofficially reprised
his character of Kevin McCallister
spoiler alert he was not doing well
Mythili and the character not Macaulay
Culkin
and people watching home at her ski
Lisa's the answer is Harrison Ford as
Han Solo because he would be great but
also he would hate it which would be
hilarious good point Dylan G langsat D H
Bruce Willis - back when he cared about
die hard
which it has to be interesting and of
course we have the Twitter poll which I
will share with you it is close I will
tell you this I will share with you when
we're done
yeah well between the cellphone knockout
which almost was a knockout because that
would be tough you what why are there so
many kids so many burglars
yeah but alright equal rule right okay I
was disappointed no one brought up the
fact that they've already made three
more sequels that are terrible actually
four I think including the holidays yeah
no good I can't use it against go to bed
so strangely you're still in this Jeana
somehow because I didn't hear enough of
the wife I'm talking about barren sean
connery great choice and really it seems
but why is he seventy with a bionic leg
because that's interesting okay you know
this goes with the poop himself nope
missile oh okay that's interesting they
are going to be a gym those but weird
and then you from a steam trap tony oh
he's old but he's young man with no name
but he's still old slightly older but
then you had a good punch with the evans
body that's what the McCulloch old would
feel like man this was tough I guess it
came down yeah no Gina's out and Justin
compared to these and I came back eaten
the cleanest would pitch which you did
have a good pitch as to why them with a
young boy is back that was a good pitch
versus the pitch which was a
seven-year-old undercover geriatric fine
yeah I think I'd rather watch Tony's oh
good I gotta give Tony the point man
Tony killer Tony you got a second point
very close parents you mean a little
younger I might have guys couldn't I
couldn't get a board based on the pitch
Dan would they say online let's see I've
been refreshing online right now 40%
voted for Sean Connery 35 from a
colleague old 25 for Clint Eastwood hmm
so very close competition is like the
Electoral College popular vote is like a
fan to agree never agree with them but
here we go around on all right round
three
this comes in from phony-baloney on
Twitter he wants to ask it on her barons
new Mystery Science Theater back in
action so excited a 14 episode yes four
Wow it's like I knew that somehow is
amazing I'm so excited I had literally
mr. Science Theater and we're not
Yankovic or to my biggest inspirations
as kids growing up and I feel like I've
obviously parlayed and honest trailers
and stuff we do here but I love the show
I'm so glad it's back but you guys you
know they don't get to do modern films
that you'll look back on older films so
we saw be fun to ask this question
number three from phony-baloney
what modern day movie deserves the mst3k
treatment and if you guys don't know the
MS III Cuba treatment get out there and
learn about it because it's awesome go
watch the old shows too but it's you
know the Tom servo crow robots and our
human pilot Weber's at the time now it's
Jonah ray was Joel and Mike Nelson but
anyway they usually sit in on the
silhouettes on the screen and watch sort
of b-grade movies and joke about it all
they're watching this a lot of fun but
if we could pick one modern movie for
them to do the treatment for what would
be bare and only fitting that you start
us off what movie would you pick oh one
of the worst movies I've ever seen
it's called Suicide Squad I love that
the title is exactly what I want to do
myself after I saw it just get a whole
squad to suicide myself it is 14
different movies rolled into one
and no one thought to to check about
that they were so desperate to be
guardians of the galaxy that they forced
it and there's a lot of great horrible
things that happen in it great actors
that get completely underused I'm think
I'm talking about Adam beech who is a
fantastic actor was in it for like five
seconds there's great moments of silence
where you can say things in between
lines I think that's the perfect kind of
movie to do Suicide Squad will make you
want to live that's the thing they have
to watch movies like are they silent
enough for me to fit the chokes in
that's a good point in anything you have
to have those awkward moments of
filmmaking where you can actually say
things yeah that happening would be good
- oh sorry sure no one's picked up
you're not convening Tony I pick XXX the
return of xander
because my god is Vin Diesel hilarious
oh my god there's so much I want to say
but I'll save it okay so but you just
want to send diesel is hilarious so
start there we'll come back Jean oh yeah
okay so I went with Twilight and the
reason is because exactly what Baron
said there's actually long stretches of
uncomfortable and weird silence in this
movie where there are also hilarious
visuals they don't realize are hilarious
like someone like Robert Pattinson quick
speeding up a tree where no one is
talking during that but I would love to
hear what the Mystery Science Theater
3000 guys have to say about it
cuz it's insane in the membrane insane
in the brain was a testing in the red
mane oh god are you oh you know I'm bad
Oscar Pitt oh my goodness
just a 90 red Minute Maid sorry I didn't
see this amazing it was awful
alright fight tone its you're more um
okay so the reason I think this thing
would be hilarious to make fun of is
because it is ridiculous
and as much as Suicide Squad was a good
movie trying to be bad and that's funny
and hilarious burger with a bad memory
oh yeah okay I guess I can smoke right
just give me a second um we'll let you
spoke so I continue Wow
got it on continued to go I'm gonna say
like here's the thing when when I saw
the answer students I thought exactly
that these two movies are too
action-packed there's too much dialogue
there's too much noise there's too much
big noise so I think that the jokes
wouldn't quite land because there's no
they're they're a mile a minute there go
go go go go talking Latin and I think
yes those are goals terrible terrible
movies but that's different than a
terrible movie that can be a good
Mystery Science Theater 3000 movie which
I don't think they
I think there's too much going on in
them whereas Twilight is like here's an
attractive man now no one's going to
talk for five minutes while a fan blows
on this woman's face for some reason so
there's like again huge huge chunks of
no dialogue no there's just like melodic
music playing and it is the perfect
place to put some comedy in there I mean
if you said Twilight New Moon maybe but
like ah no I'm joking yeah I choose like
I love that much you know what the thing
about Suicide Squad is that there are a
lot of there are a lot of silent moments
and especially like if a movie has a
huge action climax it's very easy to
turn the dial down and just say all the
things that we need to say over that
action sequence which sometimes it's
very exhausting but can be very
rewarding in the end because the jokes
climax with the movie because they're
lovers
I think it's sensory overload I think
with everything going on on the screen
it's a very busy movie to look at it's a
very busy movie to hear I like you know
that's why I think it's perfect and it
wouldn't show what I'm doing I'm going
to mess up this I can't do this too bad
MSG mst3k treatment and if you're doing
it on a modern movie wouldn't you want
it to be modernized too with with like
in some way you know change whatever it
is so it's not exactly exactly the same
way what are you talking about keep
talking about changing the format of
your show fight are you thinking you
want to change the format identity so
you're like okay everything except for
Tyler I know what I was just saying like
maybe you guys talk fast as you said to
do something more modern today with
these movies also if you're going to do
a modern movie they're always going to
be different than back in the day also
there are so many ridiculous things in
your movie but they're really twice as
bad in mind look we all have our
difficulties but the best Mystery
Science Theater 3000 old episodes were
monster movies you're guys you guys have
action down - and a literal monster
movie I've got vampires it's in the vein
of the older show which is if it ain't
broke don't fix it it's great and I'm
not all necessarily monster movies there
in modern are the category best 100 or
monster moon well all right I think this
personal picture opinion and to bed
sometimes it's sci-fi sometimes it's a
fantasy but - a superhero action movies
well if it was going to be my choice oh
all the time
you know we get Tank Girl in there we
get barbed wire in there and then we
definitely get to do a Suicide Squad in
there I almost think these two are too
easy to be honest because they are so
ridiculous and not that Twilight isn't
ridiculous I just think you if the funny
would come out because there's so much
less to work with because there's less
of a movie in Twilight because there's
less going on that they stretch out into
two hours somehow whereas you guys it's
like wow here's a new character here's a
character there's make up this person
crazy Jared Leto's or insane person
everything's going on you don't need
jokes on top of that you can watch that
yourself and your own inner dialogue
Annihilator that is what makes sometimes
the jokes get even better because you
have to compete and competition Rises
all the boats otherwise the jokes are
going to completely take over Twilight
because there's nothing happening and I
want it to take over Twilight that's
what I want from Mystery Science Theater
3000 I want the jokes to take over the
badness of a bad movie all right
you're very different than I probably
should believe I can say anything
because he's gonna change the form and
read never tackling the truth is the
person was going to yell that by the
internet for being in it at all how dare
you all same here okay clearly all right
you you lost that round so weird it's
almost fun yes sir I hear the thing
about suicide squad waiter you know a
lot sauce really between you two bottle
go ahead no I don't know I don't know
bear go okay last thing about suicide
squad the other thing about suicide
squad that I think that Twilight does
not have is at least a few redeeming
moments because I still walked out of
that movie going well Will Smith is
still good like this is the one of the
worst movies I've ever seen but I
believed him in every single thing that
he would put in however Viola Davis
that's ridiculous that's dick Euler and
I think that that's exactly the kind of
thing would I like to rip on you want
some good in the movie I want some heart
some redeeming quality in the movie
that's going to have us like hold on to
it for the whole for the whole thing no
matter how bad it is
Jeana fine fine I just feel like uh
Twilight is that bully in high in high
school that you hate so much and any any
opportunity to punch it in the face is a
good thing so that's why I want to see
this episode I want I want it that bully
to be punched in the face once again
whoo all right sorry Tony
you're out Dan yes first of all to clean
up our joke Jimmy Fallon's brilliant
Chastain in the red mane that was
actually from the Golden Globes though
oh yes he has not hosted the Oscars
hawthorn brisk and no yet completed
hoo-wee dances a lot of people suggested
throwing things at home alley cat
nineteen eighties suggested the last
airbender Lamont Cranston three after
Earth Brenda McBrayer says a battleship
deserves to be lampooned
Marcus star shines two transformers age
of extinction easily the worst movie
I've ever seen I agree with you
and Tampa buck fan 88 says Dragonball
Evolution is so bad
the jokes that would make up would be
amazing for mst3k writing all these down
we also have a poll which there's a
clear whatever I will share with you fe
really yeah I mean it really came down
between Twilight in Suicide Squad sort
of once just got to lean to the experts
in sparing knows but Gina man you really
fought that well the monster movie was a
good one
it is a movie you want to punch in the
face but he is right you want a little
heart you want to let mr. Nazir's an all
mean
so I while it was very close I got to
give it to Baron on that one I there is
I think there is moments of silence and
fun you could do dial it down and really
honestly by my man Joel would never
return my very there here on the show my
almighty favoritism because he knows not
favoritism money you might have been he
might have had an unfair advantage
merciful know I would actually work and
what I do they both would work to be
honest I thought it was what I put up my
first choice okay what does the online
damned it sickens like a student a the
Twitter poll online let me pull it up
here it is still at 51% motive for
suicide squads and 30 percent for
Twilight 19% of XXX the return of xander
cage the close but don't I see a day all
the garbage we got yeah alright round
for this one comes in from JH each
shortage JH hot edge yeah hard it's hard
edge J is Hamid if you need pliers come
down to play a childish
he wants to know what movie or she
actually understood miss assume that's
right what movie is the biggest
improvement over its source material
Tony we're back to you for first what
movie would you say is the biggest
improvement over at source material
I think the missed 2007 which was a book
Thomas drawn by Stephen King soon to be
a TV series yes dude oh really yeah
we're making a my stuff yeah I'm up to
date
haha hey but I think you reckon you
can't you can't watch everything you
know what out dog but I think that's the
greatest improvement to a
source material because of the ending
and I can go into detail if you'd like
or territory spoiler territory today yes
that's right where they all died except
the father kills everyone else to spare
them the terrible death that would come
from a month monsters you know they're
the weapons that killed his own kid he
killed his own kid and that's love
that's been spoiled and we have to go
all the way he murders them all inside
the monsters and then and then the army
and we'll just kill all the monsters has
just shown up like five seconds later
which is so sad but such an improvement
to a film because of that reason and
there's more that they changed as well
all right she didn't watch it sorry you
should have a lot of time Gina I'm gonna
go with The Princess Bride I read the
book The Princess Bride after I saw the
movie and I was expecting that same sort
of magical feeling that I get from the
movie The Princess Bride and it just
wasn't there it was more sort of like a
straight straight told story and they
include everything in the book with the
grandson and the interruptions but the
movie is so magical with Fred Savage and
Peter Falk and how Fred Savage keeps
interrupting him and Peter Fox has to
sort of win him over throughout this
whole thing and it's just so magical and
it's so quotable and the book was very
forgettable in my opinion so that that's
what I'm going for a Princess Bride
pairen Creed first of all is my favorite
band also the movie Creed is a great
improvement over the source material
witches which is rocky and specifically
I'm not going to say that it's the
original rocky as much as it's Rocky's
three through the rest Creed is one a
way to reinvent andrian vision a
franchise ryan coogler just knocked out
of the park he took me into a journey I
was not expecting to be and Michael B
Jordan I mean Michael B Jordan is like
the Michael Jordan of being Michael B
Jordan
right now you know what I mean yes first
of all you can't say the source material
is Rockies three through six when you're
talking about source material generation
Kane original Rocky is fantastic Reed is
also fantastic but that doesn't mean
it's a it's a totally different movie
exactly but it's not I would use
movement on it rocky like anything do
that it is an improvement on Rocky want
a reinvention and sometimes to reinvent
something is to improve it and to
improve something is to reanimate like
this is like biggest improvement they're
saying it's the biggest improvement also
I read the short story that the Miss was
based on and I already show no no I read
it right I read it when I was like in
high in my rules and it's crap out of me
the the short story I think it might
have been in skeleton crew of course
like fact check me on that but it wasn't
scared and crap and that movie was just
sort of like a berate monster movie that
I wasn't afraid of also the great thing
about the book the myth is that they
leave it open-ended like at the end
you're like oh my god what what happens
I don't know it you have to like leave
it to your imagination so it was it was
really like an imagination Stoker
whereas the movie and Thomas Janie I got
it you're killing your kids it's sad
it's not better I think it's better
because it makes it from a as you call
it B list horror movie or whatever into
something that is psychologically
different you know if I could put
yourself in that point of view and you
you think this is amazing this is
terrifying if I was put in this position
and that's the sign of a great that's
the sign of a great movie except you're
getting it all on the very last scene of
a movie I'm saying The Princess Bride
as a movie the entire movie start to
finish is better than the entire book
start to finish thoughts on that has
anyone can even fight that for me I have
not read the book of Princess Bride
I build honor and I've been abroad but
you know they're both a bit of Cary
Elwes um back to greed
okay here's why it's a big improvement
on Rocky's three know hi I'm Rocky
Balboa no well first of all you need the
first two Rocky's I think because you
have to have Apollo to get to of course
this young guide young about material
only abalone accretion all the rocky
four is a national freaking treasure man
why because James Brown is in it Dolph
Lundgren James Brown I will break you
ridiculous though hey it doesn't see
here's the thing
the rivers got broken first Rocky's at
least take place in a world that is real
that feels natural to that time and
they're in the Frankie you're saying is
great the first lock is good huge
imprison it is a it's a good movie that
was really good for its time and so to
improve on that like Creed is a really
good movie a great movie for this time
they were both great movies for their
time not but but this was the biggest
improvement this isn't just like hey
which is another that's the big
improvement if it takes something at a
time that you're in because what there's
only seven stories so the best movie you
can get is to adapt something into that
applies to where you are right now and
so green applies to where we are right
now thus it is the biggest improvement I
reckon pride is the world it doesn't
exist
Fred damage isn't even there in the
movie
look wait what how do we work so any
good I might get unis um so the princess
sprite is an amazing movie already and
you're saying that it's better in the
book it's better than the book yes and
you're saying that's a bitter
improvement you think you don't like
reading it's a huge improvement it's a
huge improvement over the book I read
the book and felt no magic if you can
take something that has no magic in it
but and the thing about the great thing
about this is all the elements were
there all the characters were there all
the dialogue was there but something
about reading it wasn't that special
well because you and you know here to
move here is I have to say I've had many
I'm totally going to concede because
this is very
argument and I have not read the
original book of Princess Bride but I
feel you and I just kind of like I feel
like I feel like I'm Bernie right now
I'll say it's a one person up here that
we can read and saw the missed read and
saw The Princess Bride watched all of
the Rockies and Creed it doesn't there's
not a no comparison I got the point
there you go you're crushing that right
now as well as a knocking oh the key K
whatever when you not got both of them
yeah only yo not round but we can't
doing it when I haven't read The Price
is Right and they're good move I bring
the brain blade thanks for Goldman Dan
it does yeah the online voting right now
43% are casting close to the Princess
Bride a lot of people online saying
Forrest Gump the Godfather I will jump
in and say the jaws I believe it yes
Dashiell approvement over Peter
Benchley's praised kind of be treating
so well I think the shot wasn't very
good but I really also say stand by me
anything has to do you even is a clean
line a mile about them yeah yeah sigh
greymouth inside coming out I psycho too
surprisingly doing it by the way that's
a weird fact no seriously psycho 2 is
surprisingly gonna remember in weka days
off thank you very much like a to area
remember I go to is surprisingly good it
is it plays with you because you think
this is going to suck and then it kind
of plays with you you're like oh your
hope is going to slow you just twisted
vision I got to rewatch them yeah we
were I'm going to do that Thank You male
Merc alright round 5 this comes in from
Bengie builder min this is a seed round
because Tony you're already in the
finals for speed round Gina Baron you're
tied one of you needs the point to make
it the files or Ione gets it well I'm a
tiebreaker but this is an honor of Star
Wars land they've been announcing a lot
of it they did it celebration I'm
excited for it lots of like restaurants
and same missions you're all going to be
involved in and now there's rumor of a
Star Wars hotel spaceship that you could
live in
which sounds pretty crazy so we thought
what would be the best movie to inspire
a awesome a themed hotel
what movie Hotel would you want live in
GN we're start with you I'm going with
Miyazaki spirited away which features a
bathhouse for spirits essentially for
source for friendly spirits and it is it
is there is so much insane and glorious
stuff in this back house there's Anna
friendly old man with like eight arms
that lives in the boiler room there's
delicious looking food the food and
motel would not turn you into a pig when
you ate it but even just the
architecture of the structure itself is
so glorious there's actually a like a
petition online where an artist has
drawn up what a hotel would look like
that how many how badly fans want this
hotel to exist
alright Baron I do not think Miyazaki
would want that hotel to exist but since
that movie kind of has an
anti-capitalist message to it I am going
with army Oh darkness the third in the
Evil Dead trilogy even though you will
dead - technically the remake of the
first people dead but this is stuff that
you all understand um first of all you
know as you might remember an army of
Darkness Ashe played by Bruce clam down
there yeah exactly
that was actually the age - but then the
kind of actress has Evil Dead series on
his son is actually pretty pretty badass
um so he goes he gets that back into
medieval times
that would be the hotel okay I'm from
Las Vegas Nevada
there is a hotel called Excalibur it
suck and if it was in more in the Evil
Dead vein it would be awesome especially
if half the hotel was just dead icland
and they go there after midnight to
order your favorite drink from the bar
called the give me some sugar baby
that says which is basically an old
fashioned served in a shot shotgun Wow
alright well alright we got two good
ones Tony I'm choosing I'm already
already upset about this choice it's for
twenty guys Tony's Tony is not
marshmallows are kicking and
I chose the grand Budapest hotel movie
your shot has him in the damn picture my
god sure the movie you're in it's also a
great hotel movie
I think I could have picked best
marigold hotel apparently could it well
I mean everyone okay I've got another
enough
hey parent Cortney people I'm in see
before so fine yeah people think I'm
Chris Rock sometimes I'm just like you
were saying yeah I don't think about
this I was saying the grand Budapest
hotel is already the title of a hotel
it's already ok pal talk about lazy
picking right but would it be whimsical
that's hell yeah I'm glad your hotel
what what am I going to see if I don't
tell you basically get brought back in
time like his butt to a time of the
1910s where it was a different time
before any world wars that happened
yeah 1917 the first 1/3 yeah
Cannell 13 1944 still 2010 and so you
get brought back to a different time
first off we see how the movie is
successful so obviously people would
want to come stay at this hotel you'd
have a lobby boy they're really good
work you're just get hired you know
employees I can fit my please don't go
to Cracow no but I think people would
love to come to add to the South hotel
and you would take away you know all
attachments of nowaday times which you
would have also in your spirit away
hotel and it's back in time so you're
visiting a fantasy it's both your the
great points of yours put into one thing
where you get to visit something new to
see a new thing it's wonderful it's
beautiful we have all this old history
we can have the interval landscape
skiing but usually yours is basically
just a normal hotel here and I can go
and stay in a hotel there's a place
called payback
Armitage it looks exactly like grand a
night okay nothing rooftop Bars yeah and
I want to go back to the 1910 when a
racist or sexist but though I watch them
on vacation I want to go there you know
me your family died in the war
come on man this is not even a what war
today I don't want to stay at army of
darkest hotel either where they're
trying to kill giant and anything can
happen at any time good I don't know you
the one thing spirit oh you're gonna go
with the payment the one thanks you're
in a way I don't have it's restful
enough for tonight - no no like do you
know how how quick like souls and
spirits go there to be rejuvenated so
for a juvenile Sam imagine we can do for
a normal person and it's got a delicious
food it's got awesome awesome scenery
and Laura's amazing food it's got huge
huge bathtubs that rejuvenate you you
get in plus you get to hang out a giant
baby no face weird face alright there's
like a you know it was reach me out I
bent it like I grew up in Anaheim
California going to Disneyland
constantly and seeing Mickey and all
these people answer phones and
everything at the hotel that's not cool
that's creeper grips when you hear and
you have a big which that's your boss
that you are between a normal hotel yeah
that's what people who want to say those
seems like massive massive weird themed
hotels unless they have a huge following
don't really make it the ice calibers is
hard because it's hard to handle your
Samba in my hotel the dead I turn out to
kill you except for with kindness that's
why I have them make the money though
right the hotels the theme movie so I
get to decide that the Deadites are
super nice and they're serving drinks
walk it around we're still trays full of
champagne we're selling you food and
you're like relaxing on your vacation as
is like a zombie walks up behind you
there's nothing relaxing about that you
want to see be serve food that one
doesn't have you tell your faces you can
decide which half of the hotel you want
to be in
being human Lander you want to be in the
Deadite zone manners are like when I was
a kid basically awesome sometimes we're
definitely scary minds would just be
nice but you're an adult may I want to
take your family to to a Deadite land
with yeah we could not want to be alone
a little kid brutha will look alive
walking around I think I'm glad good for
junkies because they get taken care of
because they get it now I can go to any
hotel in La si not really the coolness
that everything I've been using no
existing hotel is whimsical I it's not
res whimsical it doesn't have the
catering service the five-star concierge
and so is a lobby boy
also the Society of Cross Keys is a real
thing in hotel and they do not serve at
sea motels but they would 100% be at the
grand budapest hotel and they are the
other than gigantis again ok I want to
go back to 1914 I don't want to be
greeted by a bellboy and then be like oh
where's your husband
what should I be talking to the army
girls oh we never give that embarrass
the hope there will be a bunch of Ruth
Campbell look-alikes walking around are
called the [ __ ] that's they're very
hot they're there to help you with as
many whipped hands as you need I don't
want that all right 10 seconds each of
you go ahead last Gina your first last
final final sentence with me ok you stay
at hotel because you want an escape and
you want to rejuvenate and you want to
feel better about your life and you want
an actual vacation that you can't get
anywhere else
here today away would do that without
any of the terror or the racism of the
1977 year and it's not something that
exists already so it would be the most
magical hotel of them all
Peron oh yeah my hotel is sure part of
it is scary but you get to decide if you
want to be there you get to decide if
you're a human of your Deadite and of
course at the end of every Friday night
you get to participate in a giant battle
LARP style ok
LARP style and you get to play the LARP
psycho
morning she could to go out there and
battle some Deadites or humans depending
on who you want to be because it's at
the army of darkness hotel we let you
self-identify Tony first off to your
point about racism this is a themed
hotel we don't have to bring racism back
I don't know how raises I could be but
we don't have to bring any of that back
and this is you said they want an escape
and relaxation over there they don't
know what's happening you know it Minds
would be one the most successful hotel
to because no one would want to go to
see like monsters in a bathhouse as
opposed to just a regular hotel that has
a nice you know different feel that can
also rejuvenate you because they have
their own hot spring baths over there
and great escape into a wonderful magic
as a design on the cold land a belt all
right Dan yeah this one's actually
really tough for me so give me what you
got and then alright I'll give you what
I have
Tony's right this decided cross quiche
and grand Budapest hotel based on the
Society of the golden keys which is a
worldwide network of concierge ages and
whatnot fancy hotels yep they have thick
st. keep n so if you see a concierge
wearing that keep n that means they're
in the society to go the Keith thanks
Hogwarts Harry Potter that was the most
popular answer on his Twitter and kind
of validate that the shining was another
popular answer and Willy Wonka is
apparently the right answer for this
question because a lot of people said
they want to go to a Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory team tonight I think
it's magical and whimsical I don't know
yeah they do meanwhile at you she
touches also he will kill you Pergamon
is attributed touching the candidate
that stinks I learned the hard way that
Willy Wonka is never an answer for
anything it's not where you want to take
that where you want to go or to take
anyone of you it might end up walking to
the Tim Burton one you never know you
never know we do have the Twitter poll
which is uh it's pretty close but there
is a way any feedback from you listening
I'm having trouble this one for me yeah
hmm I will say that I think that I think
bear and got himself out of a little
trouble by saying that you can choose
yes you want to do the scary size
definitely true and I useful would enjoy
that people would I think there are
there are some people how many crews we
learn The Walking Dead is a cruise ship
Philander what they do I think that Kirk
on down for some reason that's the grant
of infesting hotels would it force to
societal norms over the time they can't
grow and that would be really that'd be
real commitment Killeen I think and but
I also agree that there's a certain
whimsical side to Gina's choice yeah
though you want to be around a bunch of
giant babies again I don't know
everybody here's the thing for the
animatronic if he if it's barren can
save at his hotel
well I know what a good ice can be made
up how are you making the spirit away
things cuz you're talking about this
magic yeah yeah I mean it would be it
would be exactly the way it is in Disney
they would either be people in suits or
animatronics whichever one looks more
sort of adorable and real-estate away
also not all of them are terrifying a
lot of them are very cute the little the
little black puffs that take her shoes
are adorable so sit things yeah the the
footballs that that he feet that the the
boiler man also smells great for and
look it was I don't think it's Tony
honestly because I think that he was
just it's a normal hotel it is kind of a
normal tells of normal fancy hotel would
be a nice thing but of all the fictional
places we could go
it'd probably eat you even said it
barren there's one where did you say
wherever there's one it looks similar to
it and the you said somewhere what
caliber ya know at the grand Budapest
you know it license friggin West
Hollywood back and
your knock of how it's and he was
against and it's anti capitalism why
would they want to be in hotel that was
a really good punch as well those two
the slide is I got to get bearing the
point I'm trying to make for told you
but those are the two points are sitting
out for me it's just hotel was the point
you had because you could say that daddy
and God can but very close pair and you
get a dummies Gina you're out but you're
not out because you're gonna help me and
you did a wonderful job
I'm having a higher you are welcome back
again anytime you're II know you're very
good becoming one of my favorites your
greatness
thank you good work now you will help me
judge the background so you get to help
determine which two will make it G the
way this works is you'll have 20 seconds
to answer and then you'll have 10 second
rebuttal as soon as I give you the
question you have to say it fast
whoever says it first gets the answer if
you don't say quick enough you have to
say something else follow you can
meditate for 10 minutes before air
control here we go okay speed round here
we go it's really fast so speedy hmm
okay I'm just remembering a chance and L
is the patient here into that obvious
quick impersonation are appeal go like
now I make everything all right Aereo
let's try this one first
worst movie featuring Harrison Ford ooh
um anchorman 2 oh me oh oh oh there you
go good one good one
I just you guys you could go no you get
to pick it on the way you gotta go you
got any money I get to say to ya bad
Harrison Ford movie um okay ha ha the
force awakens whoa okay daring I love it
no Crystal Skull was not chosen
all right here we go Tony get the first
20 seconds increment to go ahead
anchorman 2 is and it is a terrible
movie first off it rips apart whatever
the first one had and then cameo by
Harrison Ford where he turned into a
werewolf Keith may makes it way more
ridiculous and if it sucks it sucks
because Harrison Ford is such a good
actor and you know your movie is an
amazing movie um alright 20 seconds
Farren my grandmother used to paint
these paintings that look fantastic but
if you looked at them without the paint
they just had a bunch of numbers in
there and that's basically what the
force awakens is is it payed by numbers
movie and it is great because it's doing
an impersonation of greatness and so for
them to kind of take one of the great
characters of the Star Wars
Methos and reckons Tony time will begin
when you begin speaking go ahead take
your time force awakens was a commercial
and critical success you your own
opinion of saying if that is you know is
not really valid here while mind is
critically 10 seconds final 10 burn well
you know sure that's possible but also a
Harrison Ford definitely underutilized
in that film and you know meets a fate
that I was like not on them all right
based on those arguments Gina what did
you think well first of all I just want
to say know your audience dude because
okay I've got that
that's the Empire Strikes Back is like
brilliant I know but I'm a fan of all
the Star Wars universe
I feel really a few technical notes on
the argument yeah yeah I will say even
based on the arguments the fact that the
fact that 20 brought of the fact that
it's a critical and commercial success
and whereas his movie was not and I feel
like yeah even you said Harris board
wasn't in the movie enough and I think
that's that's different than it being a
bad movie that Harrison Ford is it okay
so I've got to give it to an based on
those arguments yes le barón made an
argue
for force awakens being a math movie or
perhaps one that he didn't care for
whereas I heard more from Tony about why
that was the worst movie so I have to go
cyber Tony I agree that's only the first
one will be a 5-4 more apparent awakens
it can't be the first thing that came to
my mind I'm time to thank you could you
could Assad know why high pressure is
pressure here all right here we go next
one I don't like to sorry I don't like
those treated unfair alright here we go
let's try to some what actor should play
a Bond villain any actor Tom Hardy Tony
mmm this is the speed Sean Connery oh
alright there you go Baron your first 20
seconds it begins when you begin
speaking Tom Hardy was kind of like the
Marlon Brando of our age meaning that
he's fantastic and everyone is confused
by him as a human being and so to bring
that kind of energy to a Bond movie
someone who is a formidable force as a
bad guy that's something that's been
missing for a really long time is having
some sort of criminal mastermind that
isn't just some sort of concept of an
organization huh cool Tony first I'll
bring in Sean Connery back into the
series would be amazing a nod to the
previous films as well as having an
older person who can bring such gravitas
bringing him out of retirement as well
Tom Hardy should be playing bond himself
not the villain he would be great as
James Bond because if not then the
villain would just basically be James
Bond fighting James Bond alright 10
final seconds using wisely Barron and
that's interesting they messed it up
with gold and I and I'm saying bring
that stuff back it's too typical to put
Tom Hardy in the seat you've got to be
there he's got to be the obstacles 10
seconds Tony
Sean Connery will bring a familiarity to
the series and he absolutely can play
just as much of the obstacles you're
saying than anything else maybe not
physical but definitely mentally
demanding Oh going you first test I'm
Dan baseman's arguments based on those
arguments and as a Bond fan
I felt that Baron actually brought up a
very good point of it's been a while
since we had a singular villain who
didn't stand in for a larger
organization I thought that was a really
good point so I would actually side with
Baron and that and that Gina yeah I
agree I really liked that argument and
also I agree with the fact that Tom
Hardy brings a gravitas to villains so
I'm side with Baron as well yeah I mean
when you said shun cars like whoo but
then yeah I'd like parents pitch a
little stronger I got to go Baron as
well we're all united suffering I got a
wit my for Scott awakened right now okay
here we go
who is the what's who's the best actor
that has appeared in any fast and
furious film look at the rock Dwayne
Johnson Sirleaf their own who hmm all
right the rock versus Charlize Theron
here we go
best actor who was appear in the Fast &
Furious movies so we're really just
arguing who's the best actor now yeah
you can mention tester as well go ahead
Baron rock is up first the rock is a
fantastic actor I couldn't believe how
funny he was in movies that are bad like
be cool or the tooth fairy however you
put Charlize Theron in a snow white
movie and then her real South African
accent starts to come out and it makes
you go why didn't they get a dialect
coach for this damn thing so the rock is
you just I just always believed that
dude
the rock is a great person that needs a
great personality to have in films but
he's not necessarily the best actor
we're debating what the best actors in
Shirley's our own has awards and
accolades to to support that as well as
you continue to make great movies that
are
ethically and uh successful and as well
she I mean her ten seconds I honestly
don't doubt if the Rockville in an Oscar
at some point because he's working very
hard to get to the point where he can
get there and charlise their own
sometimes people went in the wards and
they go backwards and look at ten
seconds
we're talking about the rock right now
we're not talking about the Russian
future I'm sure he has great success now
but will that lead to him being a
critically good play acclaimed actor who
tougher Geena based on his arguments oh
man I gotta say I'm undecided on this
one because I really liked barons
argument that the rock does a lot with
bad movies and is always believable
whereas Charlize Theron is and it's a
bad movies and she's bad but you're
right she does have awards and accolades
so I'm stumped on this one Sam yeah I
was leaning Tony's way slightly after
the first round and I feel like if
Barrett and come back with something a
little stronger except for the future
argument on the rock then he could have
swayed me but I think that Tony
convinced me just enough Best Actor not
best personality with best actor he did
just enough to sway me to Charlize yeah
I was slightly there as well so I'll
give the edge slightly to Tony that puts
them up by one based immaculately it did
help in those arguments but anybody's
game so here we go number four name two
actors tell me who's the best okay Emma
Thompson or Helen Mirren Helen Mirren
Emma Thompson yeah alright you're up
first Tony with Emma Thompson wait no
sorry no sorry you're right that's right
I wrote that down
Helen Mirren Tony go ahead
Helen Mirren is an amazing actress who
can be compared to Dame Judi Dench and
Meryl Streep while Emma Thompson has
never put in that category as well Helen
Mirren's movies from read to you know a
bunch of us a great women also including
assassin the Furious FA disappear me oh
yeah okay Emma Thompson's had a
fantastic career ever since she was from
from the time that she was in the
Cambridge Footlights to the time that
she was in all those other movies the
Harry Potter series obviously I also
love her in a very little-known movie
called the tall [ __ ] he started Jeff
Goldblum and it was Thompson Tony you
would far more recognize a Helen Mirren
then you would Emma Thompson Emma
Thompson is basically just inaudible I
know she is but just can't think of who
she was okay so I keep talking out your
back your neck oh okay oh [ __ ] I can
tell how much you love Helen Mirren by
the fact that you could only name red
Emma Thompson oh man come on Pride and
Prejudice and Sensibility criticism
zombie I mean I get based on filmography
drops I got to get bear in the edge yeah
that's what I got them either of you get
any of those bizarre thing that
he remembers issue at the Cambridge and
it's a weird 1989 movie called the tall
guy anyway the other thing a little
while to remember but I agree when I say
custom Agra really all I could face that
all selves I would also compose fireman
Baron if you're ever in the situation
again just bring up the one scene in
Love Actually where I am you actually
never seen the actual oh god yeah think
of a movie with Alan Rickman we need
right ok run the Oscar for the game and
fasten that seriously give them a tandem
Excalibur yeah there we go
right alright well that was fun alright
here we go hopefully you guys can figure
this one out here we go a row match from
episode 2000 best movie featuring Will
Smith Oh
particularly in separation what did you
say receipt of happiness in 6 degrees
Wow
okay not not what I expected but okay
your legitimate choices
yeah of happiness versus six degrees of
separation okay after it no no he trans
in here don't hit trans oh I am
Independence Day but hey whatever star
hand hot yeah that's really her first
history's first so fair in Europe six
degrees of separation brilliant play
adapted into a movie by John guerre Will
Smith's plays a pivotal role in that
movie and it was this first feature film
I think where he was a serious actor
while he was still on the Fresh Prince
of bel-air so he was balancing both of
those things he was being goofy
hilarious but the playing is really deep
dark role of someone that you really had
to care about Tony pursuit of happiness
is a wonderfully beautiful story acted
to perfection by Will Smith including
his son
you see those scenes and you can't help
but feel so bad for this person and cry
and it is an amazing I believe you got
an Oscar nomination for it
your film is a play and the play is
better than the movie having seen the
play alright I do think that the movie
is fantastic and I think that Will Smith
is one of the things that makes that
movie work because of the chemistry
between him and Stockard
if Nidal I sometimes I watch a movie and
I go I could see eight other people
there but it wasn't true here all right
10 seconds Tony the chemistry that
willkommen has with his son in those
situations where he's sleeping in the
bathroom are so realistic because it is
his son he holds him and you feel that
emotion and a better movie to say in and
Will Smith's youth is elite oh alright
did not like Ali
ah Gina what do you think for me a
couple things sold this uh the fact that
so I full disclosure I've seen neither
of these movies so I'm purely going by
argument here and Baron had an edge for
me because he brought a good point about
he was he was doing the duality of funny
but also eating that depth and also I
feel like your argument that he had
chemistry with his son the fact that I
was his own son to me makes it less
impressive because I think any any
parent can have real feelings and real
chemistry with their own sons dan see I
kind of edged the other way because to
me I thought that barons argue it was a
little more biographical he told me what
the film was but I felt a little more
from Tony about why it was Will Smith's
best so I kind of leaned toward Tony a
little bit there so comes back to me Wow
here it is yeah it was tough because you
did both give me strong
you knew your films I even cried because
I remember yes dr. canning we were eight
of that lost Oscar that yeah it was
these are both good performances
interesting point Oh Jean about of
course you should have good chemistry
with your son that said though I think
that sort of tipped me over a little bit
was I didn't hear any negatives against
his and Tony did sneak in the play is
better true or not I got a based off the
argument and it was even then like if it
is true that's fair and I was like you
did get a knock at the Appel opposer so
the faculty we will slide that in yeah
well they can't even spell happiness
right
I give sliders to Tony but really cool
summers are UN Wow
bare neck and neck you know your movie
sir if that was amazing thank you for
doing that and I'm welcome back any time
yet I hope you had fun
I did I did just make sure the Gina's
not here cuz she's too good really had a
great game really good three really good
players like I feel like I got where I
got on technicalities but better
anything else you want to plug coming up
I know mr. Science Theater 3000 now in
Netflix they can tune it out whenever
tune in whenever they want
yeah else you want to tell us about
Grayson Frankie also on Netflix and I
made a documentary called fatherless
which is on the fusion network why and
when it's not on there then it will be
other places but look for fatherless as
well if you have cable yeah check your
local listings Congrats man and uh
thanks for coming to blossom eating and
having younger cuz be hygiena you what's
going on with you and you might plug uh
let's see I still do my GI Joe podcast
called knowing is half the podcast I'll
check that out that's awesome uh yeah
and other than that Regular Show Season
eight just ended so if you didn't see
that you can check that out I believe
it's on Hulu are on the Cartoon Network
app loved it killing as well and Tony
ravioli oh my goodness you did do a no I
know you came out victorious very very
como o und adapting and pick your own
movie for the hotel ran I don't manage
to win Oh what did you get on anything
you like to plug um check me out on the
socials and I have a movie coming out
that you may have heard about its called
spider-man oh okay okay
Bitterman fighter pony's cinnamon so not
fun unit but goes I'm you but is he
going to plow there's a reason for that
let me go
you're playing spider-man though right
yeah you are over yeah good if you going
to prom in this or is it a different
dance you're another day right prom it's
a homecoming oh you're Hulk I am good
cool I'm excited all right welcome back
so nervous I said you like June yeah 7 7
17 yes we're going on that you'll
actually I come back closer till and
promote again oh now you're unseated I
am this is crazy that's just sweet Dan
Martin that Murrell Dan on Twitter
anything you'd like to plug no yes I'm
sure this is a very fun show amazing
competitors I can't wait to have you all
back fantastic and thank you all for
home for watching I love doing this with
you we will be here next week with some
more fun have a great weekend everybody
bye-bye I'll come back now yeah I think
are we trying real quick yeah we'll be
here if you're like all right thanks